sasquat squat
yeah Squatch
watch hey I'm Justin and welcome to
Squatch watch we're in the Pacific
Northwest and there has been a massive
amount of Squatch sightings here so
obviously it is the perfect place to go
to look for
bigfoot I am Jenna and I am here in
squim today and we are going to be doing
a lot of new things to find Bigfoot
we're going to be using DNA we're going
to be using evidence collection I'm
actually going to put my forensic
biology degree to use let's go find
Bigfoot there's this kit on the internet
that you can buy it's called feces
finder uh when you submit the test it
will tell you the genus and species of
the feces that you have collected this
is definitely going to say Bigfoot hi
I'm Bri I am not essential to this
Mission whatsoever um but I am only here
because Justine promised me a $100 bill
and not one of those old ones either a
fresh $100
bill wait a minute I didn't actually
agree to that though oh $200 what okay
$200 and I'm here Brien no I'm not
giving you any money I'll buy you dinner
no I'm not Bri you're not getting any
money keep it
warm let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go we got a bite we got a bite we
got a
bite
all right so we were just down at the
swim Hall a little bit earlier we found
a few witnesses that have actually had
actual Bigfoot sightings yes I was down
at the squim Market getting a gallon of
milk and when I got my milk I looked up
and saw Bigfoot crossing the street
ma'am how many strides do you think it
took him to get across the street oh he
was definitely several at least several
at least two strides they gave us the
exact longitude and latitude of where it
happened so we are here we're going to
reenact it so it would be like one
Squatch step and a half is 1 2 3 that
was three what does that even mean one
of the most difficult things about this
is there's no Squatch calculator if
there was a Squatch calculator things
would be so much
easier oh okay me as a Bigfoot I need to
be bigger what are you even trying to
figure out we're trying to prove if she
is a
liar who
how did the Bigfoot cross the road in
one St
St there was a compass there was a jump
and then there were strides none of that
came together what do you yes it did how
think about it just think about it I did
they keep thinking what did we just do I
have no idea she jumped in strided in
math I don't know I have no idea what I
just videoed let's go are you not having
fun no
I have a lot of fun with that $100
bill I'm not giving you any money no
seriously you
better it's I'll block meil you let
everyone know that you do not give money
goodbye I think we may have a little bit
of Squatch
droppings the Squatch calls here are
endless when I call it is like an
echoing chamber o
I have bom
it one thing that's new on this Hunt is
we have an infrared camera so we're
going to do a quick scan see what we can
see and if we see something we're going
to go squim and get it okay infrared
engage oh this is great I can see so
much stuff like I can see see in the
dark oh my gosh what Jenna Jenna come
here look hurry I think I see something
oh my gosh look look look look
look oh oh
Bri
crap what is she doing I don't know like
I don't she's going to get lost and she
doesn't have a cell phone well she does
but she's enough service hold on wait
look how far she is look at her what
does she think she's doing oh my go look
what do you see
Bri watch R it
that concludes this Squatch watch stay
tuned for some behind the scenes some
deleted scenes some bloopers and of
course most importantly our lab tests
we'll see you guys in the next episode
don't forget to subscribe don't forget
to like be sure to get yourself some
Squatch watch gear and join the Squatch
watch no luck today but you know what
they say here and squim you squim some
you lose some PE what you think for
today's hunt cold and I don't want to be
here that's is it
yeah turn right at the kitchen Dick road
driving on kitchen dick take my hand
we're almost to Woodcock oh we're in s
first dissolve a small Spoonful this is
the spoon that they gave me I mean like
really you could have given me like a
little bit more than that Justine do you
have a test tube holder what